back in june we welcomed you to betty's
village it is the first housing project
by opportunity village here in the
valley a 35 million complex designed to
give adults with special needs places of
their own well three months later i went
back to see if the village is starting
to finally feel like home
that's actually my house corey waited 10
years for this after living with his
parents his entire life his eagerness to
go it alone led here betty's village we
met him in june when he saw his new
apartment for the first time
today the construction site is an
apartment complex
welcome man it says it's good to be home
and cory's empty space is slowly it
never gets old what he's always wanted
it always is good to be home too corey's
home is already set up it's always good
to be home yes his favorite chair
favorite video games and a book case
with his favorite characters and i do
like weird things i do miss seeing my
mom and dad every once in a while that's
why i call them luckily she's not far
away it's one thing doing chores at home
you know when you have a few things but
it's another one it's the whole
apartment is yours betty's village is
unique an entire housing project
dedicated to adults with special needs
most of the tenants including corey have
some sort of disability but staff say
that's no barrier to community full of
life this is more than i could have
imagined tenants already go on nightly
walks together around the village we had
one resident come in and he couldn't
figure out how to put his coat rack
together so he came in with all the
pieces and was like help how do i do
this it's all part of the adjustment so
far it's a fun adventure i'm trying to
get used to the fact that they're not
here
you know stuff was a little bit weird
it's a little bit weird the first time
you're living on your own opportunity
village says betty's village actually
isn't full yet that's an ongoing process
should be soon they hope to build more
housing
down the line around the valley with the
same uh essential goal by the way uh
rhiannon there from opportunity village
mentioned the coat rack yeah help with
this coat rack she also said one of the
other things about the folks that live
there they are very eager to pay their
bills like almost like obscenely
interested in paying their bills quickly
and fast usually we're like oh my
goodness it's the 15th i got to do this
they're paying it on the first and like
you know the month ahead of schedule so
they're just well they're introducing i
like that method and they're making a
paycheck that's what's amazing at
opportunity village it's very simple
it's good to stop by one scene that is
so neat i love it that the residents all
gather at the end of the day and walk
together through the neighborhood yeah
yeah absolutely it's beautiful
very community oriented